hey what's up guys my name is Jonah
welcome to episode 31 the last the last
the very last episode of Network show
programming and today we're just going
to basically clear up a few things do a
few kind of admin kind of bug fixing
stuff and basically make this piece of
software ready to go so um to do that
okay first of all let me just show you
guys the kind of bugs that we have again
the stuff that we deal with first of all
there's nowhere to quit the server
cleanly we could just terminate it
that's not clean so we're going to do
that but if I start the server over here
and I go ahead and open a client so one
login I'll make a yarn localhost a one
one two as usual of course and then I go
ahead and type something like hey
alright what you'll actually see here is
is that we don't actually have it it's
weird like on Mac over here it shows
that we kind of do but we don't actually
have a termination character over here
okay
I was testing this out on Windows like a
good boy I was testing it on different
operating systems and I found that um we
don't have a slap we don't have a slash
a on the end of this and it's hard to
see here but we don't ok so to fix this
we're going to go ahead and go into
client window and inside client window
we have a let's go ahead and see we've
got a send and you can see on message we
we go ahead and we append the /m slash
the message but we don't append the
slash a slash so make sure you put that
in otherwise you have a bad day ok
because the server will receive a
massive packet and on Windows you can
actually see that it takes up a lot of
space okay important stuff so if we
launch this again just to verify our
works to be able to see that yes indeed
it'll work okay so hey and there we go
no difference visible here but on
Windows for some reason there's a
massive difference and if you don't do
that you'll see a mess of it you'll see
a scroll pane appear over here like a
scroll bar and and if you highlight the
text you can see that it's actually
going to be very long okay so we need to
do that okay really now let's talk about
the server stuff so quitting how do we
quit well we need to make a private void
um quit okay and then quit I want to do
a few things right one thing we should
do is disconnect
love our packets right so let's
terminate this because it was already
running so we should really disconnect
everyone so for in I equals 0 is less
than clients dot size I plus plus we can
go ahead and say that for each of these
let's go ahead and disconnect client
sorry clients get I dot get ID with the
status of true because the server close
down once we've done that we can go
ahead and close well first of all which
is that running equal to false right and
then after what we should do is close
the socket now closing the socket
generates an exception in Java ok and
it's it's not really a you failed you've
done something wrong I'm crashing
exception ok it's more of a UH by the
way you've closes salt etc so it's
really like a mess like a friendly
message but it appears as an exception
and you'll see what I mean here when I
demonstrate it but over here in a in our
run method here right this is the run
method I'm going to go ahead and add a
new command so you can see else if
messages with kick that's the kick
command this is the end of it so I'll go
ahead and add it an else if message dot
sorry not message what is it is it text
yeah text of equals quit yeah
we'll go ahead and we'll quit okay and
if we test this out right if we come up
here clear this we will launch the
server and then we go and go ahead and
do slash quit you can see we get this
socket closed and you can see it's not
really an error it just lets us know
that ok we've closed the socket and
determinates properly it does not crash
it just terminates and if we go ahead
and see this com Cherno thing this is
where the problem occurs not really a
problem again but if we click on this so
you can see that it appears in the
receive method now to stop it from
happening you can see that here we print
the stack trace great if it's an i/o
exception we probably do want to print
the stack trace because that is an error
but we don't if we have a socket
exception because you can see over here
that this is a socket exception so to
fix this just before this this IO
exception actual going to copy and paste
this line up
of it okay and above it I will put a
socket exception a again here just blank
okay there's nothing in here at all okay
and that will just make sure that if
it's if it's if there's a socket
exception it won't print anything
whereas if it's an i/o exception it will
now if you were to switch places with
these so if I put this small what have I
done to tell me to do that where are we
here we are now if I were to switch
places with these like this right that's
going to give us an error because you
can see it says that unreachable code
block because IO exception actually
engulfed socket exceptions so make sure
you do it above IO exception okay just
like that in a work fine now that stuff
if we go ahead and test that again you
can see that if we start the server once
more and we type in slash quit it quits
cleanly okay and you can see this
termination thing goes out after a while
so it doesn't shut down instantly
because it doesn't terminate it just
takes his time it closes all the sockets
finishes everything I just mental
clients and closes down well okay that's
good now let's go ahead and add one more
thing okay if a user types in that types
in the command in the wrong way or
something then we want to kind of give
them that feedback so else all right
else if basically all this stuff happens
if if our text here starts with a slash
because that means it's a command right
so if none of these if these type in
something like slash blah blah blah then
that's not a command let's handle that
so let's go ahead and tell the user you
know that's pretty nice help message and
I'm actually going to make it a separate
method because I'm going to do it twice
the private void print help and we can
print a nice little help message that
will let the let the server admin know
how to use his goddamn server okay so in
order to do that we can just go ahead
and say something on lines of here is a
list list of all available commands okay
and then we might just add a bunch of
equal signs just to make it kind of like
area like an underlined phrase here and
then we can add all the commands so what
commands do we have
we've got a /ro right and that enables
roll mode we don't have to explain what
that is they can figure out from
themselves slash clients right that a
lot I guess that shows all connected
clients will put a full-stop the end of
all days by the way make it look a bit
nicer more formal another thing that
we'll do is we'll print our what what up
what else is there there's kick so kick
and then the user ID or username so that
kicks a user the specified user
obviously but we have to put that in I
don't think slash help of course that
shows this we could also make it slash
question mark and ask for that you guys
can figure that out for yourselves if
you want it so prints shows this help
message and then finally the other one
is a quit right so quit shuts down the
server alright great so we'll go ahead
and print that and we'll also go ahead
and print that this is a unknown command
first on alright cool so we'll actually
make one more here which is obviously
the help one because we've just typed it
in help here
so else if our text dot equals help then
um go ahead and let's see I'm just
trying to that should have been fine
I'll work for we've got a bracket that's
all if if our taxes help will print help
okay and there you go that's pretty much
it so if we go ahead and open this again
start it we can print something like
oops so we can print out help here is
less available commands great we can
print out we're going to tighten return
wrong word we should probably are
actually let's just terminate as quickly
now if we enable wrong mode we probably
want to tell the user that we've done
that so that you can say well status in
as well
Jax equals R or if raw mode is on then
we can print something like because it's
going to be turned off so raw mode off
okay otherwise else we can print raw
mode on again you'll see what this does
in a minute probably guess already but
basically if we type in slash raw it'll
turn around now and raw one turn off
okay simple as that now if we type in
slash he'll bring to everything what
everything is if we die if we type in
slash clients you know we can see all
this stuff now if we type in slash Yun
that's not a command it'll tell us
unknown command and here's a literal
commands great fantastic that is it guys
that is the end of Network a programming
I hope you guys did enjoy it as much as
I did it was awesome I'll put up another
video probably after this one just being
like you know finale thanks for watching
everything will over and a few things
that you guys can continue with this
course don't forget that all this code
is on github there'll be a link in the
description of this video so you guys
can expand on this and stuff like that
but anyway that is pretty much it right
so the whole purpose of this series
pretty much was apart from to learn how
to make an awesome chat program like we
just did the whole purpose was to of
course uh basically lead into
multiplayer for the game programming
series so of course if you you guys are
new to my channel or whatever and you
haven't checked out the game programming
series I highly recommend that because
we'll be implementing multiplayer very
very soon but I really do hope that you
guys did enjoy network share programming
I thought it was an awesome little
series that I did 31 episodes and 31
episodes of just pure gold right am i
right one more thing that I forgot to
mention as well was that which probably
closed a little scam that we've got so
in in server end server
we've got I've got this run method we've
got a scanner that we open but we never
closed it okay so over here conveniently
in this space looks like ants Canada
close and watching move that down over
here okay
scanner door closed I'll just close out
our scanner and make java happy alright
see you guys later
good bye
you